[Música]
vamos entonces a bruselas mejor dicho ya
estamos ahí ahí está nuestra
corresponsal esther herrera para tratar
temas de la actualidad en el continente
europeo esther muy buena tarde empezamos
con la alta comisionada de la onu para
los derechos humanos hablamos de
michelle bachelet que anunció que no se
va a presentar a la reelección en el
cargo que más anunció desde su sede en
suiza esther
hola buenos dias raúl pues si en efecto
como has comentado la alta comisionada
para los derechos humanos de la onu
michelle bachelet ha anunciado que no
repetirá en un segundo manga tato en su
cargo ha asegurado que se debe que esta
decisión se debe a temas personales y
que nada tiene que ver con las críticas
recibidas
recientemente asegura que ahora es
momento para dedicarse a su familia que
esta decisión la tomó ya hace dos meses
y así se lo comunicó al secretario
general de la onu antonio guterres ha
rechazado que la decisión se toma recién
debido a su reciente viaje a china en
que debía estudiar vigilar y también
observar la situación de la minoría
uigur una minoría perseguida una minoría
musulmana perseguida en el país pero
después de la publicación de su informe
que muchos ongs y también activistas de
derechos humanos han asegurado que
michelle bachelet hizo un informe
demasiado suave en que no se estudiaba
ni se explicaba bien la situación real
de la minoría uigur ni siquiera que
apenas tocaba la situación de los campos
de concentración en los que se considera
que muchas de las personas de esta
minoría están encarcelados y contra su
voluntad chelet sin embargo ha asegurado
que está acostumbrada a las críticas
después de tantos años de estar en
primera línea de la política y que esta
decisión es meditada y que nada tiene
que ver con este informe esther dejamos
a un lado a bachelet cambiamos
información porque también hay
preocupación ante la posibilidad de un
esquema nuclear en medio de las
tensiones mundiales actuales es decir
también con la guerra en ucrania por
supuesto esto es lo que advierte una
prestigiosa institución internacional
con sede en estocolmo le pregunto qué se
sabe más al respecto
si así es el informe no es muy halagüeño
el instituto internacional para la paz
para la paz con con sede en estocolmo ha
alertado en su informe del delicado
momento que vive actualmente el mundo
según el informe la reducción de los
arsenales nucleares que se empezó a
producir a partir de la guerra fría
parece que se ha estancado que esta
reducción ya no se está produciendo y
que más bien al contrario muchos países
se están esforzando en aumentar incluso
su arsenal nuclear alerta a cuestiones
como por ejemplo el pacto nuclear con
eran que ahora mismo está estancado de
hecho las negociaciones están totalmente
estancadas porque irán está haciendo
oídos sordos en muchas cuestiones para
paralizar su arsenal nuclear china ha
también ha expandido su arsenal también
francia también reino unido han
anunciado que han aumentado el techo de
su armamento nuclear y por supuesto la
guerra en ucrania preocupa muchísimo que
rusia pueda utilizar armas nucleares
contra la población por todas estas
cuestiones el informe alerta que ahora
mismo la situación es la peor desde la
guerra fría